and tonight the price at the pump is yet
at another all-time high in fact gas
prices now have hit new record highs for
17 consecutive days no end in sight the
national average for a gallon of gas is
now well over five dollars a gallon five
dollars and ten cents by the way diesel
that costs even more
now despite what biden and his well
administration would have you believe
there's no mystery surrounding why we
have spiking gas prices let's begin with
a very important reminder when someone
tells you
you know something especially on the
campaign trail believe them
two years ago on the campaign trail joe
biden well when he wasn't hiding in his
bunker told us that he was a climate
warrior he said he was a card-carrying
member of the climate alarmist cult he
vowed to destroy the oil and gas
industry and even threaten to throw oil
executives in jail he openly dreamed of
a green new deal and promised to move
away from fossil fuels altogether even
if that meant sacrificing high-paying
career jobs in the energy sector in the
process even and even if it caused
americans you the american people deep
financial pain which we are now all
experiencing and then there was this
exchange between biden and then
president trump during a debate this is
october 2020 take a look for yourself i
have one final would he close down
i have a transition from the oil
industry yes oh transition
it is a big statement because i would
stop why would you do that because the
oil industry pollutes significantly i
said here's the deal but that's a big
step well if you let me finish the
statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy over time
over time and i'd stop giving to the oil
industry i'd stop giving them federal
subsidies he won't give federal
subsidies to the to the gas which excuse
me to the uh to uh solar and wind yeah
why are we giving it to oil industry we
actually do correct the solar and wind
that's maybe the biggest statement in
terms of business that's the biggest
thing because basically what he's saying
is he is going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma
is everybody remembering now because
president trump was right in that moment
joe biden said exactly what he was going
to do and it wasn't the first time over
and over again on the campaign trail
when he'd leave his basement biden
promised to transition away from fossil
fuels regardless of what the
consequences would be take a look
if we don't stop using
fuels
we're all dead doing away with any
subsidies for fossil fuels number one
number two holding them liable
for what they have done particularly in
those cases where your underserved
neighborhoods and you you know the deal
okay and by the way when they don't or
when they're deliberately put them in
jail kiddo
i want you to just take a look okay you
don't have to agree but i want you to
look in my eyes
i guarantee you i guarantee you we're
going to end fossil fuel and i am not
going to cooperate with you okay would
there be any place for fossil fuels
including coal and fracking in the biden
administration
no
we would we would work it out we would
make sure it's eliminated
end fossil fuels and eliminate it now
you're wondering why you're paying on
average five dollars and ten cents per
gallon of gasoline well when you
artificially reduce the world supply of
the lifeblood of our economy oil and gas
and at a time when demand is actually
growing well prices go up that's simple
economics 101 you don't need a harvard
business degree to figure it out at the
time president trump predicted exactly
what would happen
and what is exactly happening right now
take a look at this
and you're paying what two dollars a
gallon for your gasoline that's okay
you know what that's like that's like a
tax cut
that's bigger than a tax cut
if biden got in you'd be paying seven
dollars eight dollars nine dollars then
they said get rid of your car
we're gonna build some more windmills
and gas prices you like that two dollar
gas right
how about five dollars six dollars and
seven dollars darling let's sell the car
it's a little bit too large let's get a
compact
biden's plan is an economic death
sentence
oh but of course the feigned outrage
over those mean tweets i'll take the
mean tweets and two dollars a gallon
gasoline any day now of course after the
election biden did exactly what he
promised to do he killed off the
keystone xl pipeline well he did give a
waiver to the nordstrom 2 pipeline for
vladimir putin i guess probably payback
for all the business that hunter and
russia did together now he also banned
drilling in anwar he paused all new oil
and gas permits on federal lands he
restricted fracking he slowed down
production with a slew of burdensome
regulations and while he curbed domestic
production he's now more than happy to
beg other countries for oil including
some of america's worst enemies you know
iran we're gonna make iran rich again
and venezuela rich again we're gonna beg
the saudis and opec to produce more oil
he's now planning that trip to saudi
arabia then it's off again on again what
to beg for more oil from the gulf when
we have more natural resources here and
somehow according to the climate cult
you know paying foreign dictators and
america's sworn enemies to produce the
oil our economy needs desperately is
somehow what tell me how that's better
for mother earth for the climate than
producing it right here at home it
doesn't make any sense and you know
while we're on the record of this high
prices every day and was experiencing
one every day for 17 days in a row
along with a president who is unwilling
or unable to change course he is so
beholden to his climate religious cult
now doing the same thing over and over
again expecting a different result that
is the definition of insanity allowing
these policies to remain in place is
insane but that's exactly what's
happening because joe answers to the
radical ecosocialists new green dealers
in his own party so we will compromise
our national security and be dependent
on other countries we will eliminate all
these high-paying career jobs in the
energy sector
we will do nothing to increase the
world's supply which would lower gas
costs dramatically at the pump we will
give up the greatest opportunity we have
to lower inflation and reduce the price
of every item in every store that we
shop at by reducing the delivery cost
costs a lot more when when those 18
wheelers fill up their trucks their rigs
with diesel uh what just to cling to
this this climate religious cult
it is clearly way more important than
the suffering of poor americans middle
class americans americans on fixed
incomes but truth be told at this point
it's not totally clear that the
president can even think for himself at
all and with his poll numbers cratering
by the way real clear politics average
now lower than ever 38 and by the way
that includes some very favorable joe
polls that are not exactly uh in the
world of reality we call them outliers
democrats are now starting to jump ship
as the new york post put it uh say it
ain't joe democratic doubts mounting on
biden's 2024 re-election run for example
top obama adviser not a dumb guy david
axelrod said biden's age was a major red
flag meanwhile congresswoman
ocasio-cortez this weekend refused to
say whether or not she would support
biden in 2024 and look at this headline
from even the liberal new york times
quote should biden run in 2024
democratic whispers of no start to rise
and according to that report quote
dozens of frustrated democratic
officials members of congress and voters
are expressing doubts about the
president's ability to rescue his
reeling party one dnc committee member
even told the times quote to say our
country was on the right track would
flagrantly depart from reality so
naturally biden knows just who to blame
anyone but himself and according to the
washington post joe is lashing out at
his own staff even his chief of staff
ron claim now biden also frequently is
blaming florida senator rick scott for
some reason hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else